et c'est l'habitat du soir lara million
comment allez vous enfin au moins on est
ravi la rade vous accueillir cette
conseillère départementale dans le
canton de mulhouse 3 on a pris
l'habitude comme ça assez fréquemment
d'aller voir un petit peu le travail des
élus sur le terrain vous votre vie
d'homme c'est marc schittly alors vous a
suivi six ans plus tôt adrien labit vous
a suivi au programme
ça ne chôme pas visite aux collégiens
aux personnes âgées inauguration du
marché de noël plongée dans le quotidien
de nos élus regard des rencontres entre
les jeunes du collège jules verne des ac
et leurs conseillers départementaux
l'objectif de cette intervention
rapprocher les collégiens de leurs élus
les questions fusent chez ses futurs
citoyens
à quoi servent les conseillers
départementaux est ce un métier à plein
temps ou combien a coûté ce collège
flambant neuf pour nos deux élus c'est
l'occasion de rappeler aux jeunes que
leur devenir est au coeur des
préoccupations d'un département qui
intervient dans de nombreux domaines de
leur vie
ce collège j'ai été inaugurée donc en
2010 grâce à une volonté commune de la
ville d'illzach qui s'est fortement
investi pour qu'un terrain puisse être
trouvée ce nouveau collège était plus ou
moins obligatoire dans la mesure où la
sécurité dans l'ancien n'était pas
assurée et qu'il y avait une volonté
départementale rénover ou de
reconstruire un certain nombre
d'établissements dans l'urne
oui mais moi j'aime bien les oranges
clémentines à l'autre extrémité de la
pyramide des âges visite de l'ehpad le
séquoia contrairement aux collégiens les
résidents n'ont pas besoin qu'on leur
explique le fonctionnement de
l'institution départementale
mais apprécie toujours qu'on leur rende
une petite visite c'était pad est un
modèle du genre
construit il ya une vingtaine d'années
il est toujours au top et normes
d'accueil des personnes âgées
il a d'ailleurs reçu le label humanitude
qui récompense la qualité de vie des
résidents et du personnel
une fierté pour un département qui met
la barre très haut en matière de prise
en charge de la dépendance le
département du haut rhin est reconnu
comme étant un département relativement
en avance dans ce domaine et même par
rapport à deux collègues bas rhinois
c'est l'ensemble politique personne âgée
qui est prise en compte
il ya la dépendance des gens qui sont
ici d'un ehpad activement un degré de
dépendance relativement élevé il y
également les personnes qui sans perte
d'autonomie dont sont les personnes qui
sont atteintes de la maladie d'alzheimer
et pas plus tard que l'an dernier
l'établissement des écolières et est
doté d'une unité de vie protégée qui est
spécifique aux personnes démenti ces
personnes peuvent déambuler à leur gré
tel qu'il le souhaite
dernier déplacement de cette journée
chargée l'inauguration du marché de noël
de mulhouse
monsieur schittly s'est fait excuser
pour ce médecin la santé de ses patients
est prioritaire sur les festivités donc
passage de témoin au remplaçant du
binôme si ceux-ci ne joue pas toujours
un rôle de premier plan à mulhouse
ils sont au quotidien aux côtés des élus
titulaires et quand il s'agit de parler
du marché de noël c'est avec la même
passion qu'il s'en charge
cela fait aussi une fête c'est une fête
de fin d'année c'est une fête de famille
c'est un rassemblement saint marché de
noël sur lequel vous allez retrouver
toutes générations confondues
les gens y viennent entre amis entre
familles passer un bon moment
une fin de journée le week-end boire un
vin chaud voilà et se promène le long
des allées il ya des senteurs des
parfums des pistes de vin chaud qui se
mélangent et cc c'est un vrai
rendez-vous en fête conviviale malgré
une inauguration sous la pluie les
festivités sont lancées
jusqu'au 27 décembre mulhouse vivre au
rythme des et aux féeries voilà on le
voit à la rame millions via déjà il ya
des personnes âgées les personnes sur le
marché vous n'êtes pas aménager votre
peine est ce que c'est important d'aller
au contact finalement des gens qui vous
ont élu un mois je ne conçois pas de
toute façon la politique autrement
il faut aujourd'hui réduire le fossé
entre l'habitant et politique
et c'est justement en discutant avec les
habitants se concertant moi j'appelle ça
l' expertise d'usagé dont l expertise
d'usagé
bien sûr on travaille sur les dossiers
on analyse on fait des propositions mais
on va pas le faire tout seul dans son
bureau sans discuter sans se concerter
sans comprendre et c'est en fait c'est
ce qui me plaît et les gens qui me
connaissent savent très bien que c'est
vraiment ce qui me plaît y ont fait un
super binôme avec marc on a vous avez vu
ma remplaçante on a aussi le remplaçant
de marc et jean luc chic neige les
maires d'iac enfin c'est une belle
expérience intéresse à poser des
questions à jean hamel rappelle que vous
êtes conseillère départementale dans le
canton de mulhouse 3 autrement dit
une agglomération dans une ville
d'accord il y a justement ces trois
cantons six conseillers départementaux
sur l'agglomération mulhousienne est ce
que ce sont les mêmes problématiques
je veux dire entre guillemets qu'à la
campagne bat les autres des
problématiques sont transversales de
toute façon étant donné que par exemple
l'agglomération c'est bien sûr une
grande ville mais c'est beaucoup de
communes rurales donc bien sûr vous
savez le fil rouge c'est toujours
l'habitant c'est à dire l'agglomération
c'est les déchets alors je m'en occupe
les poubelles le tri c'est aussi la
citoyenneté avec la ville de mulhouse
donc que ce soit avec gens retenaient
roues avec jean marie bockel on
travaille beaucoup sur cette thématique
et puis c'est une vraie complémentarité
entre le conseil départemental
et justement les ville et
l'agglomération parce qu'aujourd'hui
avec les problèmes financiers que nous
avons tous et bien on peut plus financer
seul un projet ou être seul sur un sujet
c'est cette complémentarité qui fait
tout va mal est sorti assez aujourd'hui
on travaille beaucoup plus main dans la
main qu'avant voilà ça c'est clair
c'est une évidence vous allez bientôt
remettre des tablettes tactiles aux
élèves de 5e du collège saint-exupéry
quel est l'objectif de cette démarche
alors d'abord c'est une expérimentation
soit quand même le dire il ya trois
collèges sur le département c'est une
expérimentation on pense qu'il y aura
beaucoup d'effets positifs mais
peut-être aussi des effets négatifs
non mais je pense qu'on peut pas aller
contre son temps on a cette évolution
technologique aujourd'hui on sait que
tous les jeunes ont un smartphone une
tablette et c'est leur donner les
données importantes multitude de données
les livres le collégien avec tous ces
livres là il aura tout ça sur sa
tablette
il pourra avoir de vraies données juste
parce que souvent quand on va sur
internet et on n'a pas toutes les
données justes c'est d'accompagner bien
entendu mais c'est un outil
complémentaire pour des parents qu'on
peut pas les moyens on peut désormais
offrir cette âme aux enfants alors vous
avez en charge les finances département
rappelez moi votre métier à la base j'ai
inspecteur divisionnaire des finances
publiques voilà donc rebondi
enfin voici condamné aujourd'hui lara
millions du budget 2016
eh bien écoutez on travaille beaucoup
avec le président éric straumann avec
tous les élus ça je veux vraiment le
dire parce que quand on est dans les
difficultés si on n'a pas tous les élus
et si on n'a pas avec avec nous et si en
plus on n'a pas l'administration n'y
arrive pas aujourd'hui sur un budget de
800 millions d'euros et bien on doit
faire des économies de 30 millions
d'euros 30 millions d'euros alors qu'il
ya dix ans on avait 100 millions
d'excédent donc 30 millions d'euros
d'avoirs 11e' bas il faut qu'on fasse
des économies sur notre structure donc
eh bien en fait ligne par ligne
on regarde on diminue la communication
on diminue les frais de déplacement on
diminue les frais de structure ont
diminué de nettoyage donc d'abord on
s'intéresse à ces comme les ménages on
s'intéresse d'abord à dire quelles sont
les économies que nous on peut faire et
puis ensuite eh bien on fait des
économies et bien avec dans toutes les
directions
parce qu'il faut aujourd'hui que nos
compétences obligatoires bien comprend
force nos compétences obligatoires et
aujourd'hui mais on travaille beaucoup
on essaie de trouver ces 30 millions
d'économie je rappelle juste que l'état
nous prend 14 millions d'euros pour
réduire son déficit
on a une augmentation du rsa de 10
millions c'est donc pour ça qu'on est
obligé de faire ces économies et que
nous on serait organisme et l'état
organise pas ça c'est toujours embêtant
et vous avez également qu'il faut parler
d'argent le budget des pompiers alors on
a vu le travail remarquable qu'ils ont
fait notamment sur ses attentes à la
formidable
comment est ce qu'aujourd'hui on donne
les moyens aux pompiers de faire de
remplir leur mission
alors aujourd'hui vous savez que le
disent les pompiers donc elles sont
financées par 50 % le département est
simple quand % les communes aujourd'hui
là aussi on cherche 2 millions
d'économies pour équilibrer juste le
fonctionnement comme le département faut
déjà équilibré le fonctionnement et puis
on cherche une réorganisation parce que
même eux il faut qu'il se réorganise et
on est en plus un département atypique
on assimile sapeurs pompiers volontaires
ça c'est quand même formidable il faut
les dire et en même temps on a des
pompiers professionnels avec leurs
compétences reconnu leurs engagements et
saha vrai plaisir de travailler avec
tout ce beau monde
soixante huit mois j'ai le plus grand
respect je veux bien qu'on aille au bout
des images à dommage parce que j'ai le
plus grand respect sincèrement des
pompiers quand je le vois quand je les
rencontre je le redis et voila voila
c'était le petit coup de chapeau que je
voulais en faire très sincère merci lara
million
merci à vous merci à dieu merci à vous